>> So often in the theory of computation, we analyze algorithms in
terms of their use of resources. And it's usually time and space.
So like, when we talk about an algorithm running in say n
log n time, we're saying something about this, the time that it takes.
So if you say that it uses n-squared space, we're talking about
the, the amount of memory that it takes up as the function
of the growth of the inputs. So what sort of resources do
you suppose might matter in the
context of computational learning theory? So we're
just, we're trying to select among algorithms. We want algorithms that
use their resources well. What source of resources would we analyze?
If there's multiple possible answers, just fill in one of them.
We'll just see if it's any of the ones on our list.